i ran for president as you know uh and
there was a time when it felt like there
are game mechanics at play during the
campaign
yeah when i called it out as a reality
tv show at one point on the debates but
then i was still participating in the
reality tv show
and for me it hit home when i did
something that was totally random
where i was in south carolina and there
were there's a jazzercise class
and there were women doing the cupid
shuffle and then not
wanting to be rude i was like okay like
let me do it with you and just uh have
some fun
and i literally forgot that we had like
a journalist in tow
um at the time who just took the video
on their phone
and then it wound up and then to me
shockingly people
gave a [ __ ] about me doing the cupid
shuffle
such that it went around the
social media landscape and then it went
to mainstream news
where i was part of like uh i did a
sunday morning network tv appearance and
they used that as like my intro
clip um where it's like here's andrew
yang and he's having fun on the trail
and i was like what the hell is going on
where yeah i'm literally running out
this whole big set of ideas that
obviously like
you know i i think's vitally important
for
our nation's future and it's like but
that doesn't matter you know what
matters like you yeah cupid shuffling
uh in south carolina yeah and i i mean i
think that there's i think there's like
some legitimacy to this
and you've talked about it a little bit
on the podcast before that
you know people believe stories and like
we want to find
stories that we fit into and we want to
find stories that other people fit into
and so if if you know that's kind of a
lot of what politics is is like trying
to
tell a story around your opponent and
tell a story around yourself
and make those the most compelling
stories and more compelling than their
stories
because and like this is a shame to some
extent
but but also you know this is a
democracy
and most people do not have anything
like the amount of
time that you and i have to think about
this stuff and so we need
simplifying stories we need ways for
people to be engaged and informed and to
and to you know without having to spend
40 hours a week on it
and uh and so like you know
to some extent it's like this is this is
terrible and and
very concerning and to some extent like
those things do have to exist we just
have to be
as citizens really aware of how stories
function
and and wary of uh how
how they're going to be used to
manipulate us
so if we look at these social media
platforms we say okay there are serious
problems with them
and i have a few policy proposals that i
put out
on the trail and we launched
the data dividend project which i just
had this long meeting about
and here's where it gets interesting is
where uh this is the story we're trying
to tell to your point
is like story one when you say to the
average american
hey your data is yours and you should
have data dignity
it's about like human autonomy and free
will and then an american will hear that
and be like yeah yeah i agree with that
um but then they but they won't really
do anything i mean it's like just
click on i consent uh you know use these
platforms and just
ignore and hope for the best because
like you said i don't have any time i'm
busy
yep yeah i'd rather trade my convenience
for my privacy
any day i'll take that deal so that was
story one
and a number of people have tried that
story and it yeah
has not gone anywhere yeah and then we
looked at it and said okay you know what
our story is gonna be
they are making tens of billions of
dollars a year off of you and your data
shouldn't you get some of that why don't
we just get you this data dividend
sign up here and we'll go fight for your
right to get paid for your data
and so i'm very excited about that
because i think that's a winning story
and uh we we've now had um tens of
thousands of people sign up
um in in the first week and we were
fighting on that side
and then there were some people that
came back and said hey
that isn't the policy goal you should
have
of people getting paid for their data
because they're not going to get paid
enough and
you know it's still going to continue
some of like the darker issues that
i think you're driving at in your book
and i looked at it i you know looked at
it was like
so you don't want us to try and get
people paid for
their data because you think there's
like a better policy that
frankly i wouldn't even necessarily
disagree with like if you gave me
the power to pass like a better data
rights policy that made it so these
practices were off the table
like i would be thrilled i would sign
that but yeah you know like right now
that's not
feasible like congress is not going to
take that up so in the meantime let's
like try to activate people around us
um so i i hear what you're saying that
like
a lot of what we're engaged with is
different appeals different stories
different story lines
uh thinking that somehow we're going to
be
communicating purely on a rational basis
uh is silly i suppose
uh yeah yeah i mean i think that i think
that there's a story to tell around
rationality for sure
and i think that that will resonate with
some people and not with others
and that's what happened with my
campaign hank where
like i started out communicating very
rationally and i think it attracted a
particular tribe
of people now that tribe was less than
51
so then we were looking around being
like okay like
how can we try and get someone else to
join
this truck we've got all the people
we're gonna get with this strategy
so let's expand the strategy yeah yeah
so so that was
one of the the things that i was engaged
with uh but to push a little bit further
so if you were in the room
with let's say members of congress or
the president
or something and they were just and i'm
going to play act
um as joe biden let's say maybe i'll
i'll pretend to be jokes sure why not
um it'll be easier than the alternative
yeah yeah i mean i i think it's going to
be jones
so uh so joe looks at you and says hank
uh congratulations my um you know
grandchildren are fans of yours uh what
should we do about these social media
platforms
uh to improve things uh for the next
generation
well i mean this is so the first thing i
think is that
there are anti-trust concerns here i
don't think that youtube and google
should be the same company
i don't know that google and android
should be the same company
i don't think that aws and amazon should
be the same company
like that to me feels like there's just
too much consolidated power there and
it's interesting because like
i know some of the people high up at
youtube fairly well i think that they're
really good people and i think that they
believe that what they are doing is the
right thing for the world
but what i don't believe is that
any unelected leader should have as much
power as they have
and and and it's not power over the
government
it's power over our lives and
and so i think that we need to make
space for there to be competition here
and if there are if there is a great d
if there are these
moats that are created by these
companies like and maybe the the
the anti-trust isn't just breaking up or
maybe it's it's something other than
breaking up where
you know you prevent companies from
buying competitors which used to be a
thing like this used to be rules around
this you can't have them by competitors
to put them out of business um
or and you also just like can't like
just sort of like gobble up the people
who are going to
take your market share because like we
need
more than one and we need more than 10
ideally different companies in this
so that they can innovate different ways
they can create platforms that are going
to appeal to different types of people
there and like create um
you know tools that they wouldn't have
thought of and that are going to be
better
for folks now obviously there are
network effects when it comes to this
stuff like i upload stuff to youtube not
because i think it's the best video
platform but because that's where the
eyeballs are
and i i'm never going to change that
until the eyeballs are somewhere else
but i think that there are ways to
open that up and um
and and create and so i i think that's
that's the first thing
is to say how do we like recreate a
competitive landscape here
and whether that's breaking them up like
we did with uh
the bells or whether it's um
you know creating some kind of uh forces
against monopoly
because right now like it's great for
their stock prices
like but like there's no doubt in
anyone's mind that these companies are
building really big moats
and that they're getting you know
and they're building moats not just
around sort of customer interactions but
in
in some cases what i'm starting to
imagine is more citizenship interactions
where
we don't these aren't these aren't
companies we buy stuff from
they're companies who create the places
in which we live
and that's a very different dynamic than
like somebody who you know i'm buying
pants from
when when it's uh when it's in many ways
the the spaces on which uh
the the public discourse is had and in
places in which i sort of feel like i
live my life
that's actually a great observation
where
people i think think to themselves well
what's the big deal
like i go on these things and you know
they they reach me with
ads but you said it in a really profound
way it's like this is where you live
now you know like this is how you're
experiencing the world
this is how you're developing your point
of view
your world views and your values and
like your relationships
you know i have many many friends who i
know entirely through social media and
have never met in the real world i
started a business
that is now like i you know makes
millions of dollars a year with a guy
who i did not meet and for like five
years into running the business with him
and uh not not in the real world i mean
and that like
i i really do think that like we're
gonna eventually realize that these
companies
are more than companies and in a way
they are their own governments
and that like the board of facebook and
cheryl uh and and mark are like
the government of that company like
they're the leaders and that
we need to you know like there are
different ways to exert pressure on
them and like there's internal ways like
they're employees and there's
advertisers which we're seeing now
there's actual regulations from the
government
there's also pushes from users and
pushers from
pushes from like the creators who are
you know really big on the platforms
we need to start thinking about how we
uh like affect
the the governance of those companies
because they govern the spaces in which
we live
and and imagining and i do this you know
in the second book pretty
obviously imagining that these places
are are not companies but they are in a
way countries
is and they are countries that are you
know sort of totalitarian
autocracies like capitalist autocracy
emperor
presiding over his
2.2 billion yeah subjects
saying today you will see this
and you will like it and it will be good
yeah and and like the the algorithms now
are extremely sophisticated but i think
they're nothing like what they're going
to be
in 10 or 20 years and when i talk to
like well-meaning
uh business leaders in silicon valley
who are running these big companies and
have a lot of
you know maybe more influence than they
realize they have
um i i kind of want to ask them like not
just like how do you make sure you do
this right but how do you make sure that
once you've consolidated
this much power in one place the person
who takes over after you're gone
how do you make sure they do it right
how do you make sure in like 50 years
when you know facebook looks a lot sort
of older and stodgier and it's
sort of like on its you know maybe on
its way out maybe they're competitors
and they're trying everything they can
to to keep that shareholder value
increasing like what does that world
look like
not just what does the world now look
like and they don't really
tend to respond well with that question
i think it kind of scares them to think
50 years in the future
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you